bonjour à tous voici une petite vidéo
qui va vous permettre de peut-être mieux
comprendre
la formulation des hypothèses et
notamment la relation client entre les
variables dépendantes est variable
alors tout
rappel sur ce qu'est une hypothèse une
hypothèse est une proposition qui vise à
expliquer un phénomène en l'occurrence
un phénomène social
l'hypothèse
s'exprime généralement sous la forme
d'une relation d'un rapport entre deux
phénomènes de concepts qu'on va appeler
deux variables
la scion d'une hypothèse on a d'abord
une première variable
et une deuxième variable la première
variable va expliquer la seconde
variable
on a donc une variable explicative
qui explique et une variable expliquer
ce qui est expliqué
on peut vous dire que la variable 2 qui
est expliquée dépend en fait d'un autre
phénomène
de la variable dans ce cas là la
variable de est appelée variable
dépendante ce qui est la même chose donc
variable dépendante ou variable expliqué
sont deux synonymes
la variable deux saisons ce qui dépend
de la variable 1 qui devient dès lors la
variable indépendante ou variables
explicatives
la variable c'est ce qui fait varier ce
qui donne une augmentation ou une
diminution du phénomène constaté en
variable
prenons un exemple
la base de la cohésion sociale entraîne
l'augmentation du taux de suicide
nous avons bien de variables une
première qui est la cohésion sociale
avec un mouvement qui était si une
baisse mais retenons juste la cohésion
sociale et de l'autre côté le suicide
qui est représentée ici par un
indicateur qui est le taux de suicide
c'est bien la cohésion sociale qui va
expliquer le taux de suicide
on a donc la variable explicatif est la
variable expliqué
loto de suicides dépend de la cohésion
sociale la cohésion sociale étant alors
la variable indépendante et le taux de
suicide la variable dépendante
bien une cause
et un effet la cohésion sociale et la
cause du taux de suicide
un paysage tu ce qui peut peut-être aidé
certains c'est de remplacer le vert de
l'hypothèse par dépend à l'évaluation
certains ont bloqué sur en fonction ou
fonction de
ses fonctions deux donc ici en
remplaçant et fonction d'eux par dépens
on peut trouver plus facilement la
variable dépendante
voici peut-être le contexte culturel
influence la réussite scolaire qu'est-ce
qui dépend de quoi c'est bien la
réussite scolaire qui dépend du contexte
culturel du contexte culturel de la
famille dans lequel l'élève évolué
on a bien alors deux variables la
variable dépendante la réussite scolaire
qui ne dépend dépendante du contexte
culturel la variable indépendante
la cause et l'effet
ample qui reprit de ce que nous avons vu
au cours sur le talent notamment dans le
sport jeu les joueurs de hockey les
joueurs de football on nous avons vu que
la constitution de catégorie d'âge
favorise la réussite des joueurs nés en
début nés en début d'année
la variable dépendante ou la variable
expliqué c'est bien la réussite des
joueurs qui est expliquée par le fait qu
on constitue des catégories d'âge ce ne
sont pas les catégories d'âge qui sont
expliquées parricide des joueurs
voilà les deux variables maintenant si
je fais mon petit truc remplaçants
favorise par des pans qu'est-ce qui
dépend de quoi dans mes deux variables
c'est la réussite des joueurs qui
dépendent la constitution des catégories
d'âge donc la variable dépendante et
bien la réussite des joueurs à variables
indépendantes la constitution des
catégories d'âge
plus loin si vous avez toujours des
difficultés ou si vous voulez réviser
encore
n'oubliez pas qu'il ya dans votre cou
une fiche outils dans la partie méthode
que vous avez été distribués il ya la
semaine dernière donc là vous pouvez
toujours réviser ce qui est indiqué
dessus
vous avez les exercices du court avec
l'identification de deux variables
notamment quand nous avons vu les
neurones it
l'exercice en ligne les exercices en
ligne sont toujours disponibles les et
réactive et donc vous pouvez via ce lien
les refaire
et si vous avez encore des questions ou
si ça ne doit pas du tout elle n'hésitez
surtout pas à me contacter par mail ou
alors dans le cadre du cours
je me ferai un plaisir de vous répondre
la même façon si lors de l'évaluation
vous avez toujours une difficulté par
rapport du vocabulaire je sais que le
cover de sciences sociales parfois n'est
pas toujours
adapté à une population d'élèves plus
jeunes n'hésitez surtout pas à me
demander on verra pour vous l'expliquer
que ça ne pose surtout pas un problème
au point de vue de l'évaluation voilà je
vous souhaite de bonnes révisions et à
bientôt